you know that was improvised that wasn't  in this group but I thought when else am  I going to get the chance to kiss Brad  Pitt I'm just going to go for it she's  great I said Damien I think Nelly would  just go up and kiss Jack and Damon was  like um I think she well she could wait  hold on you just want to kiss me and I  was like oh so sue me she didn't you  might never come up again and it does  work for the character I was like I  think so and so then I did it the first  time and then we finished that take and  I was like thanks David and he was like  no do it again that really works but I  was like great I actually kissed  Catherine as well but I don't know if  that made the cut